[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube hey so
today's video is gonna be interesting um
it's gonna be just a quick update on my
life and what I'm doing and kind of what
we're doing with this channel and kind
of the things that I'm putting up it's
weird because I don't usually use these
videos to kind of like talk too much
about my personal life or like what's
going on in my head but I don't know man
like I feel like this is an important
conversation now if you guys have been
watching this channel you guys know that
the you know the the the content has
been really [ __ ] all over the place
primarily when this channel was created
people came on this channel to watch the
be very specific right it was like vlogs
rants or comedic sketches now that was
about like six years ago when I first
started this channel I'm trying to like
keep up with this thought that this is
what people want to see and this is what
I originally set this channel for you
know with that being said I'm just kind
of having a conversation with you guys
with what I'm doing with this channel
and what I plan to do with just my life
in my career in general why this is
something that I feel like you guys
should know is because you have been
there for or was every step of the
[ __ ] way now if you ask me what I'm
doing with this channel I'm doing
anything and everything and here's the
reason why the reason why I'm just doing
anything and everything and I'm putting
out content is because I just really
want to go back to this concept of doing
stuff just for fun I'll be 100% honest
with that concept just like enjoying
what you want to put out on your channel
for just your personal sake I think that
that kind of died out for a lot of
youtubers that's why you see a lot of
these youtubers they kind of like
disappear for a second and they come
back on and I think it's because when
you kind of gear your content towards
what everybody else wants you you lose a
little bit of that thing that made you
want to become a creator in the first
place now I'm not speaking for everybody
there's a lot of creators on this page
that just create because they want to
get recognized they want people to come
up to them and tell them how awesome
they are [ __ ] losers you know a lot
of content creators such as myself and a
lot of people that I do know we just
started because we really enjoyed what
we were doing I mean there was there
wasn't like this outside effect of life
what we can gain from it personally in
terms of like social status it was more
like you know this is fun and I'm tired
of working by 9:00 to 5:00 so this is
the one thing that makes me happy some
will continue to do this you know that
concept seems to be pretty pretty far
gone now so every day since I started my
youtube up again I've just been like
sitting around thinking what do I want
to do with this channel I've been trying
to gain inspiration from other people
having conversations and it's like David
what do you want to do with this channel
and what that really entails is not so
much what I want to do with this channel
is what do you want to do with your life
man I haven't had this conversation with
myself in over God knows how long was it
been like 10 years just to share this
with you guys real quick my original
goal was just to be a stand-up comedian
stand-up comedy was something that it
was all I cared about that's the only
thing I wanted to do I just wanted to go
on stage grab a mic and just make people
laugh but you know after time that that
goal started to change I don't know when
it did per se but it just started to
evolve it's like you know I can make
people laugh through other things you
know screenwriting YouTube comedy
sketches or just being myself and slowly
that stand-up comedy bones started to
die and not to say that I don't want to
do stand-up anymore
but it wasn't my my reason for living
you know and that flipped out from like
music and then you know to wanting to
become this amazing screenwriter to you
know now wanting to be an actor so
basically to sum it up I actually don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing I used to
wake up every day with like a pretty
like sharp laser focus and to be honest
with you
the the last time that I felt so like
inspired to do something was when I
worked on
the film goop I just to tie back to Who
I am as a person the reason why I do
things I did goop because I believed in
the project and I wanted to work on
something that you know would say
something and would last and I wanted to
work on it with my friend Justin a lot
of you don't know this cuz I haven't
said this before but prior to me
actually doing goop almost everybody
told me not to [ __ ] do it isn't that
[ __ ] crazy a lot of people when I
told them about this concept or what I
was giving up like not being on YouTube
for about six months to do this project
people are like yo man but that's not a
good idea like it's gonna be a black and
white film it's it's about a very touchy
subject do you think that's a really
good career move you're not really gonna
get paid from it and I just told them
like first of all [ __ ] you I don't think
even sometimes my peers understand how I
how I run and how my mind works
I don't yeah like a dollar is important
but I don't know I feel like we're all
gonna die Sunday and you can't really
take that money with you so if you're at
a point where you can financially
support yourself and the people that you
love I mean what more do you [ __ ]
need so in that moment where we were
shooting in creating [ __ ] it was it was
a time where I was very very happy it
was it was super super difficult it was
hard to kind of wrap my head around you
know how fast things were moving but you
know after goop became very successful
as you guys know like I've been going
into auditions and you know a lot of
doors have been opening up for me
however this is this is like the the
issue that I have this is concept of
striking when the iron is hot meaning in
this case like when opportunities are
presented to you you do what you can you
snatch that [ __ ] up and you make sure
that you take those opportunities you
become successful something like that
problem with the way that my mind runs
it's it's not so much about opportunity
has always been about what makes me
happy as of right now I'm just I'm kind
of like searching for that again like
guk was that big thing for the past
couple years of my life that was kind of
getting me up in the morning and having
to become a better person a better actor
or a writer or whatever it is so when it
comes to this channel and if you're
looking at this and you're wondering
again what the [ __ ] is he doing why is
he doing so much random stuff is because
I'm nothing you know I'm trying to find
out what makes me happy so a lot of
people don't understand when you're a
creator to like
you you have to figure this stuff out
like for me because it's not money
because it's not like social recognition
I can't do half the things that other
people are doing on a daily basis
that'll keep me going you know it's not
it's not the same you know these content
creators and you know like I'm not
knocking them for enjoying what they do
but if I wanted to do what they do or
continue to upload on a daily basis I
actually have to give a [ __ ] about what
I'm doing and so that's what this
journey is about it's about finding what
to actually give a [ __ ] about people can
tell you that you're you know you're
blessed you have all these opportunities
as much as they want but it really
doesn't [ __ ] matter unless you give a
fuss about it yourself
you know people can tell me all the
stuff they want like you know you got
assigned to this top agency bla bla bla
bla but the one thing I don't think
anybody cared enough to ask me was like
do you even want to do it I think I'm
like so confused about what I want to do
well who I want to be I'm trying to be
everything at once like I'm trying to be
like this Swiss [ __ ] Army knife like
I'm not really good at one [ __ ] thing
anymore it's like I'm trying to do
everything and I feel like my my insides
are being like ripped apart by like
eight different [ __ ] things like if I
can I want to take myself to split
myself in the [ __ ] 14 million people
so if you're kind of looking at me like
man I wish I could do it you know David
is doing and I'm pretty sure he's not
going to do stuff that I'm going through
man I am no [ __ ] different than you
look like I'm going to the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] man if you're trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] you're gonna do for the
rest of your life I'm trying to figure
that [ __ ] out as well like you're not
alone in that [ __ ] you and I are in the
same [ __ ] boat a lot of lot of
questions of you guys asking me like you
know what should I do with my life I
can't tell you what you should do with
your life because I don't even know what
the [ __ ] I want to do with mine I can
only tell you that you're not the only
person that's wondering that [ __ ] you're
also not the only person on the world
that struggles with it either you know
on the outside a lot of us seem like we
have our [ __ ] together and it's it's
it's not the case there will be people
like me and you who want to do
everything at once but we just have to
figure out what we're gonna focus on one
at a time and
know that for a fact that kind of kills
you when it kills me too but we're on
this journey together and I don't have
my [ __ ] together like you guys think I
do that's why this channel is so crazy
this is why you guys don't see me do
like set content lately because I don't
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
like I'm trying to figure it out so what
you should expect from this channel
should be a little bit of everything and
anything I might be a daily vlogger I
might make sketches I might do whatever
it's really just to figure out what the
[ __ ] I want to do and if you guys want
to stick around for it please do and if
not then I don't know [ __ ] it
[Music]